you can tell a lot about a person based
on their shoes and today there's a ton
of options in 2018 Footwear was a 250
billion dollar industry with over 24
million shoes produced globally just
look at Kanye his shoe and apparel line
is valued at 1 billion dollars the
problem is lots of shoes especially
sneakers aren't made to last they're
made of plastic and we can't recycle
them so a lot of them end up as trash
so the question and sneakers become
sustainable the average American in 2018
bought seven pairs of shoes but let's
focus on the sneaker which wasn't always
so popular here's where it started it's
the late 1870s well in tennis becomes
popular which allows men and women to
compete against each other or tennis and
chill that game also created a new
must-have item these
[Applause]
[Music]
sports became really popular basketball
Babe Ruth
Jack Dempsey golf by 1919 almost 20
million pairs of tennis shoes were being
produced in the u.s. brands like Keds
converse and PF wires launched the very
beginning of the sneaker market
[Music]
this is pencil Footwear design Academy
and this is Dewayne Edwards it's found
shoes are very complicated also one of
the first black Footwear designers whose
resume includes la gear Skechers Nike
and Jordan
so plastics made their way into sneakers
in a few key areas first in the outsole
for support and then in the heel counter
for structure in the 1970s jogging
becomes super popular companies
introduced polyurethane foam into the
midsole which makes jogging more
comfortable but they don't stop there
they start to focus on the athletes the
goal was if you can make their Footwear
lighter then you can make the athlete
faster mold the DVA replaces
polyurethane in the midsole which
immediately cut the weight down in half
almost
normal simultaneously synthetic leather
is introduced into the upper which
impacts the fit weight and maybe more
importantly the design my name is nuclei
of an answer I am the founder and
creative director of the foot press
nikoline is a Footwear forecaster and
shoe designer her job is to see trends
before they even happen
everybody could imagine classic sneakers
for instance that you collect from the
late 80s or the early 90s often now when
you open the box the sole just crumbles
away
that's essentially what happens to
plastics and that's also why it's
difficult to have a plastic shoe recycle
it into another plastic shoe so right
now
shoes are essentially a hodgepodge of
materials which means when you want to
recycle an old shoe your options are
donating it grinding it or throwing it
away and that's a pretty short life
cycle but the future it's actually
really exciting as consumers there are
more sustainable options than ever
before the world Footwear 2030 report
predicts that the sustainability will
drive innovation in the footwear
industry and
already happened big brands are
experimenting with things like
biofabrication like using mushrooms to
grow the materials for their shoes and
3d printing which significantly reduces
waste during the manufacturing process
one example of this is the adidas future
Kraft loop here's how it works
a shoe only one material you can grind
that up take it back to pallets melt
that again and turn it back into the
same TPU that the shoe was made up but
companies still don't know how many
times that process can be repeated
another consideration can a sustainable
shoe still appeal to sneaker culture
sustainability right now does not have a
design language you can hold up a
sustainable material in a non
sustainable material in the form of a
synthetic the textile a leather a
plastic a foam and not be able to tell
the difference that's a problem if you
want consumers to truly embrace
sustainability you have to win the
aesthetic game and the aesthetic game is
allowing sustainability to have its own
natural aesthetic
so back to the question Ken sneakers
become sustainable it's going to come
down to how much companies are willing
to invest what consumers want and it's
technology can drive the change that
will give us a material that's well
better than plastic
[Music]
[Music]